yesterday we got a brand new
announcement courtesy of IGN turkey
exclusive who didn't tell anyone
including yourself but today we found
out for realz that there is a new
ubisoft game coming next year in fact
februari 16th far earlier Barry over
februari Lake via early in the year late
februari ok Far Cry primal as well it's
been said was a trailer ever at the
moment which apparently has got a bunch
of gameplay showing off the game in
action Justin first of all what do we
know exactly about Far Cry primal well
we we know that it's a far cry game
obviously I mean when you see the
trailer you see the gameplay like this
is obviously very clearly a far cry game
you're gonna be exploring you have the
kind of cool melee weapons bow and arrow
spear like that the gameplay definitely
feels reminiscent of the Far Cry series
and in this game you but you don't have
guns you don't have a lot of the other
mainstays of the series instead you're
going to be set during the Ice Age or
you're going to be looking for and
fighting against other cavemen basically
and it's not clear how that gameplay is
going to work out whether it's going to
be a multiplayer game or whether it's
going to be something like rust or like
completely survival not mozzarella
horbet of survival game with in that
atmosphere but you are going to be
fighting against these guys both for
territory and to you see people taking
down woolly mammoths fighting against
saber-tooth Tigers like the the animals
that were alive during that period and
in trying to survive and create your own
weapons and baap in that environment
it's interesting because that whole rust
you know that the survivor like even
minecraft survival maps and there's a
bunch of the especially in the PC spaces
bunch of games first-person games
primarily which are about you know
getting equipment building up defenses
fighting antagonist like the forest is a
game and played a lot of last year which
is very much like that and but most of
these games tend to be multiplayer
focused because of the very reason of
like creating a I to be able to be
working teams is quite difficult but
when you look at this trailer a lot of
this looks like it's a single-player
linear stuff right 104 cry what I read
in the the feature that we actually
posted on the site earlier today is that
it is according to the developers they
say it's a
single player focused experience I don't
think that you know rules out
multiplayer necessarily it's possible
that there will be a multiple air
component in addition to any single
player but what I've read so far it is
single player focused and in theory your
character who tames the wilderness all
right quote from one of the developers
so I have a feeling we're going to be
instead of riding jet skis and
gyrocopters we might be riding mammoths
or saber-toothed Tigers or other
era-appropriate animals and shooting
humans and shooting animals and doing
all that good work so let's talk about
that then that's the sort of interesting
thing Scott we were talking before we
went live about how far cry is sort of a
mainstay of the first person shooter it
is it's kind of the game that
popularized in least in the mainstream
the idea of the open-world shooter which
has become sort of ubiquitous over the
past couple of years but it's very much
a game about like outposts and shooting
people with guns and big explosions so
there's a lot of interest in like this
is very much you know incredibly
different too far cry matically at least
yeah interesting to see how they
compensate for the lack of technology I
mean especially given that far cry 3 and
four were so vehicle driven I mean again
I just mentioned the gyrocopter you had
all these you know see vehicles commonly
known as boats yes I look like a jet
skis and other things that's what I
meant and truck and I'm out jeeps like
oh yeah where the game worms oh yeah
that's all been around you it's like far
cry 2 yeah so yeah given that you know
so far cry 1 yeah yeah it'll be to see
how that impacts the gameplay I mean in
theory you can you know throw a spear
you can you know that's a you know bows
and arrows apparently in the trailer so
they can sort of compensate for the lack
of automatic weapons in certain ways but
yeah it's justthe matically it's going
to be so drastically different it'll be
interesting to see which gameplay
pillars actually carry over and how much
it feels like a far cry game I mean I
think yeah outposts are a really
interesting example I mean that has
become a mainstay of the Far Cry
experiences you know clearing out
enemies from a particular territory and
claiming it for yourself and it's an
idea that was even carried over into
assassins creed you know greater and
greater importance in fact a lot of
carryover between all of these series
including wash dogs and everything so
yeah like are we going to have outposts
in Far Cry I'm where you're like going
up to the top of a woolly mammoth and
any good why and looking around well I
think there's gonna be there has to be
some aspect of that some some part of
that gameplay the interesting thing is
sit if it's not going to be a
multiplayer-focused game this is
obviously a game where you are you have
a group like you see the whole cutscene
behind you where you're not just a lone
wolf taking down this woolly mammoth by
yourself you have a group of guys behind
you is are you always going to have this
PC group kind of following behind you
and hope that about taking over these
things it's interesting because we're
looking at the far cry 4 intro here and
like we see a lot of this before a game
like far cry comes out like far cry 3
the story trailer dad was all about you
and your buddies and whatnot and in both
cases all of this stuff got was like
done and dusted within the first 5 10
minutes of the game so I wonder if a lot
of what we're seeing of primal as well
is you know just the setup and then
eventually you're sort of that your own
devices and it's not as linear as you
think that seems to be the case again
from the article that I was reading
earlier today your character is the last
surviving member of his hunting party
right is what I've read yeah um so in
theory yes all of the people you see in
the trailer who you're hunting with are
all gonna be dead well that's gonna be a
little easier to make yes he was true we
saw difficult it was for valves get Alyx
Vance to you know play along for an
entire game so I imagine like three
other people will probably be a bit too
much yeah I every feeling there with me
some some casualties pretty early on and
then came yeah sounds like it lots of
emotions I imagine yeah so many of all
the emotions and so I guess prehistoric
games are the the new thing 2016 right
are there other wait what you priests
were games am I forgetting I did well
arc well okay prehistoric-looking wasn't
the one that I've mentioned prior to us
rolling which I don't know if you're
hinting at but a horizon zero dawn which
was a hit at e3 and has kind of been
pretty dormant since then as far as i
know i haven't seen much coverage of it
but it has a similar like you are a
hunter fighting against the wilderness
you have you know bow and arrow and
you're sneaking through the brush
against you know outnumbered or not
outgunned but like outs teeth I don't
know when you're fighting I dinosaurs
are the genes yeah and obviously that's
like a post-apocalyptic setting so you
have leftover technology from it from
the modern era and primal will not have
that since it takes place you know
Debbie Sierra but still like you can see
thematic similarities again it's there
it has an end of the world kind of vibe
euro
horizon so it'll be interesting to see
how similar those two games end up being
but I immediately thought of horizon
when I saw the trailer for primal yeah
very much I guess in terms of its
aesthetics anyway very similar and also
in terms of the hunting so it's going to
be interesting whether this lands closer
to horizon zero dawn or whether it lands
on the other side just in the the Rost
side of things where it's very much a
game that is a sandbox it's not actually
this linear sort of story lad thing
because Far Cry kind of skirts that line
right it's there is a story happening
but really it's sort of like an
open-world sandbox for you to [ __ ] about
it and they've said they are they've
made it clear that it's not just going
to be like the other games where you're
finding all these weapons you are going
to be crafting and creating and trying
to discover basically new technology and
everything's gonna be new technology but
like there's gonna be a huge difference
between like using the whale jaw lovers
are using a bear jaw versus using a wolf
jaw other way you find a whale yeah all
the weapons you could make out of a
whale yeah well back then you're gonna
be literally inventing everything yeah
like you're gonna be the person who made
fun fun yeah they're gonna yield yeah
you could have like television internet
you're just gonna it's like all this
knowledge you already have going into
the game I know I want to play the game
where you're playing as somebody in like
prehistoric era with the mind of
somebody from 2050 what if they're just
M night Shyamalan is what if this is
like the village it took place in 2015
all along like the game ends with like
you know the characters from far cry 3
crashing into like wait a minute and it
just turns out it wasn't priest or yeah
you know hauling can you see an obscure
go logo yeah exactly like no also coming
together well Donna so the thing that
horizon has is that it does have these
huge creatures and beasts that you're
minding against is that kind of stuff
going to exist in Far Cry at all I mean
far cry they've established that this is
somewhat realistic but Far Cry also
takes a lot of liberties with reality
and that's something that I want to see
benefits mostly as well think they it
makes it fun it makes it exciting and I
want to see dinosaurs I can't haha I
like I know it doesn't like I know that
didn't exist dinosaurs did not exist at
the same time as man but I still want to
take down a team out of tomb raider one
can get away with it i'm sure far cry
and can get away with it this time at
last question obviously when we see a
unnumbered title to a far cry game
immediately comparisons to stuff like
blood dragon comes along do either of
you know if this is going to be full
price to be expected to be you know
mid-range is it's not dl Suey you know
that I do I don't think they've been
very clear on the price I mean it's
coming out very soon it's very soon it's
gonna be based on far cry 4 obviously so
I think that'll limit what they have to
put into the game that I mean that
doesn't mean it's not going to be a full
experience like a full Triple A game
does that mean that they're gonna offer
it at a lower price because they were
able to put it out more quickly maybe
maybe not I wouldn't be shocked if it's
a Blood Dragon kind of situation if it
was like a forty dollar very substantial
standalone but not a full title given
that it isn't numbered it is coming out
very soon and in fact yeah I mean it
leaked sort of a day early it seemed but
the fact that I mean I hadn't heard
anything about this until yesterday so
that's pretty impressive we made it
through con season and III impacts and
blah blah blah never heard a word about
it like leaked early but it's still
coming out in about formal yes yes so
like I honestly don't know what to
expect we haven't really received
indication from Ubisoft one one way the
other I mean again the fact that it's
not numbered leads me to believe that it
could be a Blood Dragon situation but
who knows it could be a full sixty
dollar wide deep experience alright time
will tell we'll have to find that acid
thank you very much Justin scoff coming
out talking all about far I thank you
for watching let us know what you think
of Far Cry primal you're looking forward
to it and I guess the main question is
would you like it to be a sixty-dollar
game or would you like something a
little bit smaller like blood dragon not
many games come on in February so maybe
the former for me let us know in the
comments below